[Musique]
si derrière votre écran vous imaginez
que le monde de la télé réalité
s'apparente à un rêve éveillé l'envers
du décor parfois se révéler toutes
autres seat race entre affaires de
drogue de prostitution de criminalité en
tout genre les candidats peuvent être
confrontés un milieu extrêmement
dangereux et malsain
il ya quelques temps trois candidats des
anges de la télé réalité était venu
dénoncer ce qui se passe et hors caméra
lors des tournages
la production de sel elle est fournie
par la production de la des affaires de
drogue sahra préseau avait raconté être
victime de chantage concernant la
diffusion d'une de ces six pays
maintenant que je veux me faire part
avec ça bahia personnes qui me fait peur
et je la balance moi même en fait et des
affaires plus graves de supposées viola
avait fait grand bruit en fin d'année
dernière j'ai alerté plusieurs
productions je n'ai jamais fait ça de ma
vie ça n'existe pas si la télé réalité
peut parfois faire rêver les plus jeunes
ce milieu peut aussi se révéler
dévastateur alors faut-il interdire la
télé réalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors majoritairement sur le plateau
c'est plutôt non avec cette phrase
importante il est interdit d'interdire
n'est ce pas alors vous alors lui le
guen l'a fait star
arrive oui mais
la télé
grecque c'était la star ac a été créé à
la base pour concurrencer le loft il
trouve que par la suite ils ont sondé
tiens il ya peut être un truc à faire du
côté de la chanson et on va faire un
télé crochet au départ c'était larmes
pour contrer le loft alors dit
pourquoi je devrais monde qui n'arrive
jamais vous concernant la télé réalité
nrj adapter les trash scénario doit pas
les mêmes choses c'est bien dit ça aussi
moi je dis oui parce que faire arrêtez
arrêtez je pense qu'il d'ailleurs
peut-être un peu plus de contrôle s'est
elle arrêtée c'est bien ça marche on le
voit les audiences on la met peut-être
contrôler un peu plus et les dérives
plus largement elles sont plus là dedans
ça dépend ouais ça dépendra aussi alors
je pense qu'il faut juste contrôler un
petit peu plus parce que c'est vrai qu'à
quand même une cible assez jeune qui
regarde et peut-être quand on voit
l'évolution il ya peut-être des dérives
qu'il faudrait contrôler parce que c'est
vrai que c'est ce qui est gênant après
l'arrêté bien sûr que l'on s'arrête lui
l'eau mais c'est l'explication je donne
écoute un peu ça tu fais toi tu le
regardes pas tu vas peut-être ou
peut-être fixe le
duo france je pense qu'il faut juste
contrôler un petit peu plus sa voix là
pour éviter les dérives on va demander à
nicolas nov alors dans les fonds ce qui
a deux choses il ya la télé trash et la
tnt latérite et l'idée depuis des années
de la rue faisait de la témérité c'est
la réalité dans le quotidien des gens à
la télé trash et quand on demandait
régionales jouaient les rôles nicolas
real n'a arrêté on parle d'un tel a été
qu'on voit aujourd'hui femme des
marseillais des aventures croisées de
l'amour pour moi pour moi désolé summum
de la bêtise du néant avec aucune valeur
qui a regardé par des millions de jeunes
et je pense qu'il faudrait revoir en
ayant de moins en moins oui mais enfin
bon ça a été quand même regarder suivie
par des millions de jeunes je pense que
c'est ce sont des miliciens des
émissions si elles ne sont pas un peu
codé et encadré qui peuvent être
dangereuses les valeurs qu'elle véhicule
sont catastrophiques c'est l'argent la
drogue la prostitution dans l'état
alors
dans les émissions con con qui passe en
ce moment télévision ils font panier
poésie de la drogue
n'est pas le sens inverse n'a jamais de
son sein un personnage qui sortent de là
et qui sont des gens on a été très bien
c'est débouté assurant les gens derrière
guingamp il ya sûrement des gens très
bien mais c'est une caricature de c'est
une caricature pour moi c'est une
caricature schomisch bah moi j'adore
quoi franchement j'en ai regardé
énormément il se trouve aussi que je
sortais souvent et les fans qui étaient
plus jeunes et du bouki qui était devant
aussi et franchement j'ai toujours mon
pied
regardais à la télé avec l abbatiale
soumah pourquoi on est des bonobos
vivent des bonobos
nouveau bah oui oui
j'en ai un la non mais moi je trouve ça
très beau il ya des codes voilà mais il
faut connaître les codes faut pas tout
prendre au premier degré franchement il
ya des trucs on suit les personnages
dernières années alors ah ben c'est
toujours un peu les mêmes choses qui se
passent un tel sera avec alex tallon
spongieux moi je regardais même sur les
réseaux sociaux les suv que ses paires à
moi je trouve ça drôle c'est un bon
moment voilà mais il faut prendre ça
pour ce que c'est voilà c'est latéralité
c'est pas trash c'est un jeu ça peut
scénarisé c'est très bien fait toujours
des endroits proches maintenant c'est
que on va voir après des dérives qui
sont pas dans les programmes qui sont
autour des dérives sur la vie en général
alors on va le montrer les factures
anormales fokam très attachés quand même
bien des dérives partout il aurait
déjeuné rives avec des acteurs avec des
animateurs bien sûr tous ceux qui ne
montrent pas leur village 24 donc on
entend moins et de quoi boire courant
doit se remettre en question l'ade et
l'a été aujourd'hui lé rig tous les
programmes du visuel cela dit on on
retrouve dans les magazines dont les
concours de chant dans tout ce que tu
veux aujourd'hui le pou plate et la
série réalité et un terrien tout non nrj
12 a arrêté la production de sa réalité
w9 aujourd'hui se repositionne sur de la
série réalité avec en jeu typiquement la
bndes j'ai alors en train de produire
une action quelle belle et djè mais
alors c'est l'algérie et bennett g
de télévision
à peine les 50 où vous allez avoir les
meilleurs candidats de la télé réalité
qui vont aller dans un château pour
relever les défis et trouver qui sera le
meilleur donc oui on ait pu l'envoi par
contre il agit quotidiennement il pas
être un enjeu on est dans un jeu
aujourd'hui donc il ya ce virage que en
train d'être pris par les jeunes
libéraux à moi je alors je vous dire je
pense pour l'avoir fait un petit peut
tolérer fait je pense que le prêt à vous
donner c'est que la télé irrité n'est
plus direct que les problèmes sont fait
trois mois en avance et que les
personnes qui sont dans les programmes
passent leur temps à se filmer et qu'on
les découvre pendant des semaines et des
semaines en temps réel et qu'on leur
donne la preuve qu'il m jc palme
revenant je parle par rapport au fait
que ce soit rs mois après concernant les
dangers on va y venir maintenant on a
parlé de la drogue la télé réalité il ya
eu plusieurs scandales beaucoup d'entre
eux ont été désamorcées et démonter on
avait parlé de cocaïne qui avait été
filmé en fait c'est pas du tout la crise
était apparemment une rayure voilà mes
mais on va pas se mentir magali là je
m'adresse à vous il ya eu mais comme
d'autres dans d'autres d'autres métiers
ou dans d'autres probable mais il ya eu
des problèmes de drogue en télé réalité
oui mais alors à l'intérieur des
programmes il ya quelqu'un qui est venu
témoigner qui s'appelle vincent shogun
qui a dit qu'il en a pris c'était que
c'est chaud good the bad & couteau lui
sait gré mon film chaud mais il a été
nul qui s'était caché ils étaient cachés
pour en prendre il l'a dit sur ce
plateau conquis mais il ment pas voilà
maintenant ce qui a été reproché c'est à
dire la preuve donne ça non la prod
donne pas d'abandon on peut pas dire
qu'il ya la télé
il ya de la drogue de partout c'est un
problème et c'est un fléau partout
s'il y en a deux orgues en a dedans il y
en a partout sur
les agressions sexuelles il y en a aussi
partout du harcèlement il y en a partout
en fait je pense qu'il faut pas figé
quand on fait de la télé réalité le
problème c'est que c'est un sujet qui
est sensible parce que ça fait polémique
ça a fait clic et parce que ça marche et
ça ça fait sauter des sièges voilà m
nico tout de suite oui ça représente le
nez en sortant de le vide et c'est
réducteur ce que tu dis c'est toi qui
donnent une mauvaise image tu sais
pourquoi parce que dans ces programmes
il ya des filles qui sont très bien
qu'ils sont gentils qui sont
intelligentes qui sont posées qui sont
déjantés des personnes bien pourquoi tu
les juges et pourquoi tu dis que
forcément elle représente l'union
magali nicolin
je dis juste que johnny ne regardons pas
françoise mère de kelly ses choix à
l'image de
cultiver son il faut des trans et
de divertissement la téléralité c'est du
divertissement on n'a jamais dit que
c'était une fabrication strueth culture
excusez moi c'est pour faire rigoler
c'est du divertissement faut laisser à
sa place et faut arrêter de vouloir
mettre ailleurs mais pour arrêter aussi
de vouloir toujours taper sur des gens
parce que c'est facile ça voudrait dire
que ce sont des filles qui sont vides
moi tu te rappelles quand on a fait le
débat avec olive holly dc où on nous a
approchés mais eux mêmes été refaite et
alors en fait c'est parce que j'étais
sans refaire je suis débile mais c'est
quoi c'est quoi c'est
[Applaudissements]
très bon comportement des magrets
docteur oui et ça ça mollit magasin mais
là où il accepte cette fois vous avez
raison à moi je vous suis pas ce que je
vois là j'ai commencé avec la témérité
mais c'est vrai que l'image qui ressort
globalement et on va pas juger c'est
plutôt des gens qui sont refaits et de
la et de l'arrêter mais les points non
sinon messi a donné les noms
non soyons
standard physique oui mais elles sont
comme ça zodiac arrêté mais s'y
attendait comme un mariage
mais c'est pas parce qu'on a des lèvres
fait et des
centaines arrêtées aujourd'hui vous avez
des grandes stars en terrasse bien oui
vous avez my bah oui avec l'argent qu'on
est beau bébé panda mais devrait parce
que ça ne va pas sans défaut comment non
prenez mauvais parce que star mois pour
bosser alain delon et
jean dujardin clp
maguena il est très sympa mais ce pas
une star vous plaisantez mais malgré mes
sens dans la rue kargar meshoe quand il
était dans dax choix de la vôtre
non je vous ai mes shoots en boîte de
nuit mais c'est aussi méchant youtuber
et il a une cote de popularité de fouet
quand il arrive
c'est pas ça une star
[Musique]
jean gabin jean gabin est mort il faut
aussi des
termes très vagues ali tu seras d'accord
qu'il faut faire attention aux côtés un
peu aussi oui il faut faire date arrêtée
mais le côté drogue et/ou faut essayer
de contrôler ça parce que justement les
données
diffusées non pas de capitaux n'a pas
dans les points il y en a partout peut
pas dire ça c'est lui c'est pas vrai
jean pascal a trompé le champ alors de
seconde latte sur le sur la drogue on
est d'accord sur deux choses 1 c'est pas
les prod ça je vous le dis ça n'attend
que ça circule mais oui et ça sent le
vécu sur le loft et sur les sources
écrites parce que ils ont des venir mais
par des biais qui n'était pas dû à la
prod mais c'est pas la faute de la
production on
va aborder l'avant la prostitution et ça
c'est vrai parce que je l' ai vécu et je
l' ai vécu non seulement j'ai vécu
c'était dans mon programme il ya des
gens qui sont une autre téléréalité dont
le métier premier était effectivement un
mec qu'alger ça c'est un fait on n'a pas
eu ça non mais ça ne pouvait pas dire
que c'est pas la peau des princes et les
oraux du coeur qui font les castings qui
doivent être plus vigilants avec son
caddie sablage que vous êtes drogué non
c'est bon vous pouvez y aller est-ce que
les prostituées non abbas est bon mais
il est un travail auquel et vous croyez
vraiment mais vous voyez vraiment que
les prod alors qu'il
s'était un jour le 4c sommation
le casting chic pour savoir si on est
fou c'était vous êtes fous non non c'est
vrai vous pouvez peut-être nantes a même
si le maire parce que ça dure elle
voulait pas j'ai rien dit c'est bon tu
brilles l est et pourquoi site a été
l'accord tu veux pas faire de latéralité
ce que le problème en un mois j'ai pas
du tout dit ça s'étudie turlan 2010
voilà autant de refus d'anna le fait
d'avoir mes candidats qui sont un peu
fragiles on année pourquoi la
chronologie on a un extrait sur la
prostitution et on en parle juste après
j'aurais été des productions embauche
des [ __ ] on le sait très bien et ça les
arrange bien parce que ça fait de
l'audience ça fait du scandale et
surtout les candidates qui se livrent à
la prostitution bas du cou ont beaucoup
moins de mal à se lâcher à l'écran ya
pas que des filles effectivement il ya
des garçons qui a accompagné des gens
puissants ou des gens qui sont dans la
jet set à des événements à des soirées
qui effectivement comme je le raconte
dans mon livre aller jusqu'à coucher que
je me rappelle d'un vieux monsieur qui
hébergeait chez lui un candidat de télé
réalité et qui avait un petit peu une
salle à la 50 nuance degrés une salle sm
et ce jeune homme à la base et héros bat
subissaient des châtiments corporels
avec ce vieux monsieur qui lui payait
beaucoup de sacoches ou évitons beaucoup
de voyages des séjours sur des voiliers
images de sa sas et jeremstar donc il y
va un peu fort ouais mais toujours
parler sans avoir de mai à la plus alors
je vais arrêter ce que j'ai vu moi et
entendu de bellevue dans les points de
suture envoyé mon nom dans la boue que
j'ai présentée puisque avait des moments
où on est on est suivi 24 24 on a
entendu certains candidats et par
certains candidats et candidates
d'ailleurs expliqué que le problème
c'est qu'ils perdaient beaucoup
d'oseille à faire ces élections parce
que pendant le même temps ils n'avaient
plus leur métier à côté après je suis
d'accord avec toi c'est pas parce que tu
fais tu fais ce métier là que tu
formates et des rythmes à l'apologie
mais de là à dire que tout ce qu'ils
font là telle a été sondé prostituées
elles surviennent en mai magali a
fouillé on est parce qu ici on dit tous
ces bateaux autour de la tnt et on le
sait bien que ça circule pas mal en tout
cas les gens et les garçons en
particulier et d'autres pays se
rapprochent des fils de télé réalité
c'est la vérité mais les filles de télé
réalité elles sont approchés parce
qu'elles sont hyper exposé parce
qu'elles sont des compte instagram qui
grossissent parce que ben ouais donc
forcément elles sont elles sont moins
bons mots mais moi je suis pas le
physique d'une téléréalité fin j'ai
toujours montrent de plus en plus moi
non mais arrêtez mais je vais faire je
veux dire et quand on a des follower les
gens ils viennent vous envoyer des
messages c'est enfin voila c c'est
malheureux c'est triste mais comme vous
êtes connus vous avez plus de demandes
vous que quand vous étiez pas connu donc
je pense que c'est ça qui rentrent en
jeu faut arrêter de dire que la télé
réalité ça véhicule de la prostitution
parce qu'en vrai je trouve ça hyper
réducteur je trouve ça hyper macho avec
tours ça circule beaucoup opinion
circulent quoi autour de ces arrêtés
mais on sait très alors à côté on va pas
des rois pam a lancé ici mais le nom
banal
la prostitution se font autour de
l'argent circule autour de la visibilité
se clôt tour de plein de choses alors
bien sûr vous avez des filles qui sont
jeunes qui vont sortir des arrêtés qui
vont sortir en boîte de nuit qui vont
s'exposer qu'ils vont rencontrer des
gens et qu'ils vont en faire des
mauvaises rencontres ça ça peut arriver
comme vous avez des filles aussi qu'ils
commencent à virer bien chez elle et
qu'ils n'ont pas envie de sortir et qui
n'aiment pas aller en discothèque qui
n'aime pas parler aux gens et qui vous
quittent leur famille leur cocon et il
n'y a pas d'histoire il ya de tout eh
oui quand tu dis ça leur fait la société
même si je dis ça et passer leur fait
d'associer teillage de tout dans une
télé réalité vous avez camilla qui n'a
rien à voir avec maeva et pourtant ils
s'adorent et elle se respecte parce
qu'elles sont tolérantes et parce
qu'elle respecte leurs choix de vie
chacune voilà c'est tout et c'est ça ou
moi je suis pas d'accord avec vous c'est
que vous voulez ça jette dedans et vous
avez vous n'avez pas été honnête sur les
mots
n'est pas honnête soit ce qu'il ya
autour et je vous dirai vérité tu vous
pouvez pas dire cela dit la détresse que
ça me coûte mois deux à chaque fois de
défendre la téléralité et de défendre
tout seul c'est ce que je me fais
défoncer lancé sur les réseaux sociaux
et croisez vous savez ce que ça m'a fait
mal et fort de ne pas manger trop salé
ne m'attendais que c'est pas des
pharmacies pour moi justement de dire ah
oui alors à bas la téléralité abo
magique non messi parce qu'en fait
politiquement parlant c'est ce que
certains ont envie d'entendre mais moi
je vais pas dans ce sens là et je dis ce
que je pense et je dis ce que je vous la
raison voilà et je les connais c'est si
je les respecte a dit avoir décollé
avant que je veux vous poser une
question personnelle oui lorsque simon a
décidé de faire une émission terry t il
profiter votre fils
c'est comment vous avez réagi vous mais
moi j'ai très bien l'asie parce que je
joue là je rejoins magali si vous êtes
une personne normale
équilibré et que vous rentrez dans ce
métier et dans cet univers normalement
vous n'y a pas de raison que ça se passe
mal si vous êtes fragile et on en a vu
des gones et la fragile rentrée nous on
a eu effectivement si tu rentres avec
une avec une faiblesse soit morale soit
et en les pressions et en enlevant les
ddd cas très graves
quand tu rentres fragile et notre erreur
à nos producteurs se draper des gens qui
étaient fragiles et on savait qu'il
était fragile et a souvent effectivement
il ya des dérives mais si on est
normalement constitué on était là on est
candidat télé réalité il n'ya pas de
problème après concernant la
prostitution les sages au litre coûtait
sur sa malheureusement ça a été ça c'est
pas du toit mais à la télé qui rend ses
tableaux fille mais c'est vrai que
attend et ça a peut-être changé mais à
une époque
certaines filles venaient vers la vérité
parce que c'était une façon pour elle de
se connaître mieux et de vendre mieux
encore parce qu'effectivement le marché
est gigantesque mais encore une fois
j'étais signer là dedans de crem et
charles en 2010 cette fois je vais
jamais je ne vais jamais peut que
condamner le théâtre mais ce que j'en ai
fait je suis né de ça et je pense je
continue à se situer normalement
constitué que tu es un sur voilà que tu
es sans esprit mais voilà que tout va
bien il n'y a pas de raison que ça ait
malgré tout ce qu'ils ont fait à ça
comme du thé fragile malheureusement
pour certains en sont morts il faut
appeler oui rachat ils ont ils morts et
d'autres ont très bien réussi voilà fin
de l'histoire et avec quoi ça vous avez
raison voilà c'est tout ça je suis
d'accord sur l'atlantique effectivement
il ya des clés des céphalées qu'auraient
les castings c'était pour les chaînes
qui analyse était prête à prendre
absolument telle personne jouer c'est un
bon perso au risque et on méprise on le
fait que
les fautes il faut pas les placebos